[Applause]
question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now hear
me than you so much that made
[Music]
Mead happy New Year Happy New Year
can we still say that or not I say it
until February 1 okay all right then we
got that I love that whatever was going
on out there in the pit what was that
what was that there's always so much
chaos now that I'm live streaming on
Twitch and there's just always stuff
going on Andre because Monday we're
always evolving and and progressing look
at look at your look at your title there
look at me and my fancy title this is so
exciting by the way I was on that
recording on Monday where uh where
you're reaching out to all the Instagram
guys telling them to get the over
to Twitch right now that's exactly right
we're actually it's really fun unlocking
creators and culture obviously we'll go
into it but let me just make this
statement for everybody live streaming
this is the year of live streaming Tik
Tock shop Tik Tock live twitch um even
if you're doing what I'm doing I'm
literally Twitch streaming in my office
all day 90% of it has no audio
wow but it's like background ASMR for
entrepreneurs and Executives I unmute at
times and say what's up we do random fun
stuff and I for me obviously where I'm
at hundreds and hundreds of people watch
that which is not thousands and
thousands and tens and tens of thousands
like I'm normal because of course it's
can only be so comp compelling of it's
if it's unmute but the same can be said
for everybody else and maybe six people
watch you or 12 people watch you but you
build from that and then obviously
people wish I was doing this when I was
building Wine Library I'd be unmuted the
whole time and I would be streaming for
12 hours a day I think live streaming
live stream shopping it's the Rave I
highly recommend it yeah and it's cool
how you're were talking about how
there's so many people that are working
from home and they can just have it sort
of on and that there's all kinds of use
cases now that are so different from
before and you know super fire up that
this topic is a really great one to kick
off the year with and we're hearing from
tons of Brands different experiments
that they have and how they're looking
at who creators actually are and trying
to bring in their their consumers and
their customers in all kinds of
different ways and all the changes on
the platforms as well right so lots of
cool stuff today that's for sure it's
gonna be a great show I also want to say
for everybody who's watching who's
either a CMO or a senior executive or an
entrepreneur with let's say a business
doing 10 million in Revenue a year so
big business or more uh obviously you
see Andrea's new title we are up to
something you'll be hearing a lot more
for me and us but if you fit that
profile especially the the 10 million
year or more Revenue businesses I think
I I think what we're up to me you James
orini we've got something pretty
profound coming from Vayner X and uh I'm
really proud of you and excited Andrea
well thank you I couldn't be more more
fired up especially hit hitting 2024
it's gonna be a big year across the
board but it feels like there's a huge
opportunity to bring our communities
together and we've got so much Firepower
whether it's with entrepreneur or
Fortune 500 and not just the sea Suite
but you know all those that are on the
rise in their community in their careers
how we can help everybody out um and
learning about things like this you know
what's the latest in marketing but also
how can we be happy while we're growing
our careers and you know that's
something that the only way to grow
something sustainably is to be good
emotionally yourself that's right yeah
how can we learn to love ourselves and
and create cultures that aren't all
based on fear right a lot of the big
ones that's what they they unfortunately
really thrive on I think that's right I
think that's right anyway creators and
cultures my final part before I let you
take over the show um relevance is the
biggest opportunity for every business
if something's relevant to them then
they consider a buy it and many people
are missing the mark on relevance and I
think popular culture culture pop
culture and creators creators only live
on relevance they don't have as much
awareness yet they're building but they
win on relevance is a topic every
marketer uh who Tunes in for marketing
now should understand and I think we
have a crazy lineup and I'm excited for
the show it's going to be good um Gary
just one question for you though like as
as you're looking at the work that we do
and everybody every brand wants to bring
creators in right but it feels like the
dynamic and how you you know how do you
get the best out of a relationship with
a Creator are there any any things that
you think people should be mindful of
yeah I mean you have to give them
complete freedom and every brand doesn't
want to do that if you don't like what
they're going to do then you don't have
to pay them and you can cancel it but
you've got to let them have freedom
because they built their Audience by
knowing Their audience and they know it
will be authentic and your brand doesn't
want to be associated with them anyway
if they mail it in that's what a bad
endorser is influencer is so the the one
thing I would say to everybody is you
got to let go your brand is not in
control with you to begin with now go
search your brand on Instagram and Tik
Tok right now you're control anyway so
let someone who you've chosen make it
relevant and if you don't like where
they're going with it you don't have to
have it posted or go out but you got to
give them 100% creative freedom and what
about um on the platform side you've got
your book that's upcoming uh underprice
attention what are you what are you
seeing now any any tips or things that
people should be thinking about yeah
like when I think about the new book day
trading attention I think about its
platform and its culture obviously we'll
talk about culture here but to your
point platform why is live streaming
matter to me why are images with certain
fonts working on Instagram why do the
first three seconds of this have to be
like that on Facebook so creative
strategy the science around the art is
the next Frontier of battling for
organic reach brand awareness relevance
and occasional virality and um I'm
obsessed with all of it and so to answer
a question like of the second uh images
are over indexing on Instagram again in
a way that's interesting um uh green
screen videos so taking
an image and then being a human talking
over it continues to over index the
Baseline of organic reach those two
things stand out all right they call me
over I gotta go do your show love you
love
[Music]
you all right it's time to bring up MMA
Johnson MMA where are
you hello is happy Thursday well happy
Thursday and I hear you're calling in
live from Long Island City is that right
here in our fabulous studio in Long
Island City we got 're shoting some fun
video stuff over here oh my goodness
well M about it now but it's coming okay
sounds good we'll keep mom's a word Mya
is one of my absolute faves she is SVP
of creative Excellence um does just
Stellar work and very excited to bring
up our first guest today Ashley Cole
she's the VP and this this is a title
this is a title Ashley content strategy
development and distribution
at Visa uh just amazing and she's an
award-winning Global content and media
leader and she's got quite this the
history both in finance as well as in
Tech having come from Intel Microsoft
and Charles Schwab were so fired up to
have you on the show Ashley take it away
guys good to see you how are you Ashley
I'm great it's so nice to talk to you
and just so everybody who's watching
knows Ashley is not only a super
experienced and talented marketer she's
also one of the most lovely people
you'll ever meet so please please reach
out and say hello um and she's an
incredible creative partner but I'm so
glad that you're joining us today as we
talk about unlocking creators in culture
and I think for you you have such a
unique take because you've worked in you
know the financial part of marketing for
so long so I'd love for you to kick us
off as the first guest on marketing for
the now in the new year um if you could
just talk a little bit about the role
that creators play not just in culture
but in driving the economy and really
why that's so important for Visa yeah uh
so happy to be here thank you so much
for having me and I'm very passionate
about talking about creators not because
we've nailed it but because I think it's
such an interesting part of the
marketing ecosystem for us right now and
so thank you for having me um well why
does Visa care is a is a good question
or why do I care even as a marketer and
I think the the key thing I think about
is like all this wonderful creativity
and all this creativity that's in
platforms and Gary just talked about
twitch which is incredible that live
streaming live is huge events are huge
we can talk about that more but I think
one of the things that's interesting is
that creators need to get paid right
there is a friction in the system about
like how you get paid and the way you
get paid and and we care about um the
Creator economy and the way that they're
making money and how to take friction
and complexity out of it and how to make
transactions um more attainable and so
they can get back to creating and more
energy into that so we think of it as a
virtuous sort of Circle of uh creators
being small businesses and they're
trying to make it in their in their
pursuit of their next steps in their
journey and we're here to help them do
that um you know one step at a time and
Bea the way they get paid so that's how
we no I think that that's super
important and as a as a creative um
myself not I wouldn't necessarily call
myself it's interesting because it's
it's it's the biggest thing that you
care about as a you know human in the
world but it's the thing that gets
talked the least about and to your point
is is the biggest pain point and you
know I'm sure we've seen Tik toks and
you know tons of creators talking about
that process so with that um would love
for you to talk a little bit about what
visa has been and I know will be
continuing to do um to connect to
creators um you know in a real way and
again to your point make it easier to
pay and get paid um if you're you're
will to talk about those programs of
course of course from a from just from a
um support system we've got two programs
that we have and one is called the Visa
Creator program and that's that's geared
towards entrepreneurs who are are
working in art music fashion film are
serious about incorporating nfts in
their business model or they just
mentioned nfts and I know that's not
like the topic dour but it's really
critical to think about like well what
how do we help you with that because
it's all you know digital currency and
how do we help you with there we also
have a Visa ready um Commerce program
and this helps creator Centric platform
Partners like social video gaming
companies all and everything in between
because it's not just okay well it's
just the big platforms and it's Visa
it's a there's a lot of technology that
comes in between that we partner with
everybody we're we're we're about that
really partnering with an ecosystem to
help people get get paid um but that
helps you with tools and um and sort of
features like creater payouts and yeah
subscriptions and other ways to get
connected to ecosystem players so you
can find a way to get paid and I think
that's great from marketing Point um we
did a we recently did a program in in
three regions so North America um in uh
the Middle East and also in Europe
around um what we call a get paid
program and and it was it was matching
it it understood that there was this
unmet need about like I just need some
advice right if you're on your way to
making it but you just need to like get
some advice from those who have you know
how do we create kind of a series of
content that helps creators learn about
you know how to make it and so we paired
um rising stars with others who have
made it in food fashion and oh gosh what
was the last one food fashion and music
music yes thank you and we uh um we
brought them together to just sort of
exchange ideas and help um help each
other kind of understand how to work
we've did it across platforms but what's
great about that content is it's
accessible to everybody and you kind of
get some good tips and tricks on how to
how to get from one place to another so
we were trying to fill this sort of
mentorship Gap too that exists so we do
two things we try and create marketing
um programs with creators that helps
them Thrive and we also have real you
know real tangible product connections
for creators
so back and look at some of that content
because I could use it myself good I
know yeah um and that's one of the
things I was gonna say that I think is
so interesting is the way that you all
have been able to take what are truly
pretty complex topics right when we talk
about the Creator economy when we talk
about getting paid when we talk about
finances those are all things that I
think people automatically just tune out
out to because they feel like they're
getting lectured to or they feel like
it's too complex to understand and I
think that's something that you and the
Visa team have done an extraordinary job
of is taking these things that feel very
overwhelming and that people don't want
to talk about and breaking them down
into really easily accessible
understanding understandable ways and
putting them on forums whether that's
Tik Tok Instagram other social media
outlets and make them easily accessible
which I think is is so so important um
with that I I wanted to ask you a little
bit about you know knowing what you know
and your experience with working with
creators what are some of the things
that you think the biggest brands
whether in finance or outside of that
sector get wrong about creators and how
to talk to and connect to them yeah I um
I love this question because I think
it's we're all work in progress like
this is about well how do you partner
with anyone who is an internal right you
have your own culture and a in a company
uh we do too at Visa it's actually a
really great place to work so just want
to give that a a moment of I it is a
really great place to collaborate and
work with people in a global company so
hats off to visa from that standpoint
but we have our own culture right so if
you're saying Hey listen I'm going to
partner with other people whether that's
creators or even agencies like how do
you create the best relationships and I
think one of the pieces of advice I'd
have for you know ourselves at visa and
for any other brand is that um don't
make this about a transaction like make
this about a relationship make this
about a relationship you have with a
creator um find out what is interesting
to them or what they're really you know
they they're they're very expressive
about what they're interested in but
understand their story understand their
steps to making it really get a a
feeling for what what they're about and
that makes it far easier to create a
mutual place of trust and growth for
each other so you're not just
transacting for you know hey to talk
about my brand or talk about my product
or please sell it's about you know what
are we doing together overall I can help
you you can help me we're in a relation
relationship and that's where um the
content really thrives in an authentic
space um when you're not just
transacting you're partnering no that's
really important and again I think
that's especially important you know in
the financial sector where it can feel
so cold and I think that's something
that you guys have been doing a great
job of breaking down the barriers of so
amazing advice for uh all of the the
CMOS that are on this call um I know
we're uh we're going to run out of time
quickly but I did have one last question
again in the spirit of you being the
first guest of the new year and
everybody's intention setting um what do
you think are the biggest opportunities
for Brands to be relevant for creators
yeah um I this is a recent uh feeling
for me that and I've been talking a lot
about with my team I've been talking a
lot about with your teams is that I
really think that um real life events
are actually very interesting space for
us to think about from a Content
standpoint so I have the you know
content strategy development
distribution what this means is I care
about what we make and how we distribute
it as one thing and the strategy around
it and now I'm increasingly thinking
about what the opportunity is around an
event now we're all in real life or you
know mostly back in the office or
there's a lot more travel or this and
that like but I think that there's this
hybrid of what do you learn in digital
which is great today that we're all
learning and talking in digital worlds
but also what do you learn in real life
I think marketers have an amazing
opportunity around what kind of content
you can create on an event if you do
that purposefully and you think about
not only the moment in time and who's
there and how to get how to kind of
create content with strategy and then
also create an evergreen content um
strategy from that event I think um you
can go places this is not just events
that you make for yourself or industry
events but it's also events you
participate in so they can up kinds of
flavors and so I've been thinking a lot
about that in 2024 as I think about our
calendar ahead we Visa are um sponsors
of the Olympics which is an enormous
event for us um so we're thinking a lot
about what happens before that and
during but it's also other places and
spaces that we're thinking about in real
life and I I think the connection
between people is needed you know oh my
God people are craving that and I think
that's why the Olympics are gonna be so
big this year is because it's kind of
like that first big event I don't want
to say postco I don't know when that
happened but um the other thing that I
just wanted to say to that point that's
just again a a tip for the other
marketers that are watching this not
only is it a smart um use of those
dollars and a way to connect to people
it's really important because it also
helps you drive down the cost of
creative I know every person listening
to this is thinking about how do I fuel
the content machine and how do I
continue to build my brand on social I
think one of the things that you guys
have done extraordinarily well is use
all of your sponsorships and your events
um not only to Showcase creators but use
it as an opportunity to create hundreds
sometimes thousands of pieces of content
you know in the event of the Olympics um
to really fuel your social engine and
create more opportunities to connect
with them so just small kudos for you
guys we're working on it it's always a
work in progress MMA I love it no you're
you're doing great um no thank you so
much Ashley I don't know if there's any
you know final thoughts you want to add
on just some of the work that you guys
have been doing in in connecting
creators and culture but again Visa is
one of those beacons one of the biggest
most prominent brands in the world and
you continue to lead the way here so we
are so honored to have you today and
thank you for being our first guest on
the show it's a pleasure thank you for
having me Mya good to see you cheers you
too fabulous J oh my God what a Little
Love Fest over here this is how we start
the
year thank you so much thanks Andrea
bye all right next up we're going to
have a conversation with two of my
favorite Chief brand officers let's
bring up uh Miss Mary Kate
McGrath I love it what a great combo we
just witnessed I know it's all it's
juicy stuff it's January it's a big year
2024 ready ready to learn and expand and
what a way to start the year let's go
all right well very excited to have our
very dear o join us Chief brand officer
of Mesa I didn't realize that Mesa is
the world's largest beauty incubator in
Mass that's a that's a pretty that's a
pretty uh a big statement there um main
portfolio company and she oh you've got
quite the list of responsibilities here
innov incubation brand marketing
integrated marketing and creative Studio
doesn't sound like there'll be a
shortage of conversation in this one
certainly not thanks for joining us I'll
I'll leave it up to you guys ah thanks
oh it's so good to see you again how are
you my dear I'm good how are you thank
you for having me oh we're so happy this
is such a treat um I think Andrea nailed
it you oversee so many brands at Mesa
and I think that people know those
Brands individually but not maybe that
they're under one roof will you Orient
us again with the brands that are at
Mesa and your role at the company yes
absolutely um I I do love to say I'd
never have a dull moment you know
there's every part of my brain that's
functioning in different capacities so
as um as Andrea already mentioned you
know all consumer touch points um
reporting to me so whether that is any
product that we developing whether
that's a new brand new product
Innovation um creative Studio who brings
beautiful ideas to life you know all the
brand marketing efforts integrated
marketing press social influencer and
then marketing operations so so all of
it I love it because it just helps me
cut out the politics the
Everybody's In It Together We have a
disagreement we power out together my
five directors we come together and we
solve problems we move on you know
that's the best thing about having such
a vast responsibility you're able to cut
through the crap pretty quickly versus
having to politically navigate a lot and
I'm sure a lot of us have to deal with
it
myself and then the brand that we have
is christas um Hair Care um it's it's um
it's a huge brand at Target and um now
nationally available we have Heritage um
which is a brand that we've created with
Mindy mcknite who is the number one
YouTuber mom uh we have a brand with her
daughters itk but also Drew Berry
Moore's uh makeup brand uh Flower Beauty
traj P Hansen's brand tph Hair Care
being Frenchie which is a brand that we
just launched with Ashley tasell which
to a huge success Target and then also
lastly finery and cozy place which are
two homegrown fragrance brands that we
have and this is not to mention the
private label business that we do but
this is I think plenty for us to gr best
it's incredible and your and your career
has been highlighted by successes that
across category in Beauty and it's it's
just such an honor to have you is there
a shared approach to using and employing
creators at
Mesa you know um I would love to say yes
so I think the science of it is very
similar right like how we're going to
measure success how are we going to
create kpis and Roi and like I think
even in the previous conversation they
were talking about that when you create
your earned media and Creator L uh
marketing you know your your overall
paid performance improves because people
are talking about you you're just a more
relevant brand right so in that the
science of it very similar in terms of
the team structures that supported very
similar in terms of the Creator
selection very different yeah right
every brand has such a unique point of
view in in how they want to operate it
and we don't get in the way because
relevance and cultural fit is so
important because otherwise you're
micromanaging and fine-tuning the
content that comes to you it never meets
your expectations versus you kind of
just have to lose in the Reign a little
bit it's very uncomfortable as a brand
owner you kind of just have to let go a
little bit and and and let the brand and
the creators do their thing which is
hard right I mean because you're kind of
saying this is our you know we talk
about this a lot right that decisions
shouldn't be left into the boardroom and
that happens right like you've made this
product and then you put it out into the
world and someone else either loves it
and or hates it obviously if you're
employing creators hopefully it becomes
a nice flywheel but tell us about how
you think about that or what's the you
talk a lot about culture and in the
company how do the brands think about
that and release that kind of onus to
over to the
Creator right I think um I think overall
you know just taking a step back back in
the den we were joking about it years
ago creating a TV ad and two print
commercials was it right one year one
TVC one year one TVC that was exactly my
life and and you know it just Brands
controll The Narrative and it was a
one-way communication and we were
talking at the consumer and over the
years you know that pendulum swung and
then pendulum became the influencer Le
sort of model and and and that's where
the it swung and I firmly believe that
it's it's going to swing again and it's
going to go into the user generated
content space right so the user space so
where the brands used to be in charge
now consumers are in charge and and it
is isn't just stating the true fact
truism fact you know it is the actual
truth of just what's happening so I
think as a brand the as a brand manager
the only thing you can do to get in the
way of the success of your brand is to
get yourself in the way of the brand and
the Creator right so I think um I think
just knowing that your brand no longer
is a one-way communication it no longer
is what you're telling the consumer it
is a sum total of the content you put
out there and the creators who speak of
you right so the goal that you should
have is that how sharply defined have
you created a brand how sharply have you
selected your influencers therefore the
communication that they're having about
your brand actually fits into the larger
picture for you I love it so let's talk
more about that sum total of that
content that you described um which I
think is so relevant to the conversation
today you recently had an incredible
moment on Tik Tok you and I are huge
fans of the platform walk us through
what happened and any learnings or
insights for the for the mass audience
that's here today of what happens when a
creator takes hold of your brand or your
product and and all things go as you
want them to go but what exactly happens
inside your office and outside no
absolutely so so so number one thing and
it was um we started the year with being
Frenchy going viral with one such
content piece you know and it was just
such an exciting moment you're starting
the year you're just settling in and
boom guns a viral moment and it was like
yes exciting we're going to go in front
of the board and we can talk about it
and and and actually saw the impact of
that on Revenue as well literally two
weeks in a row you saw greater than your
typical run rates in terms of growth
rates right so you you see a direct
linkage and gives you more confidence
that what you're doing is actually
working so what happened was uh we of
course you know as part of our mailing
list our our team sent out product but
of course kudos to them for finding the
list of creators that relevant right and
one of the influencers um created the
content piece and she happened to be a
huge fan of Ashley toelle and sort of
grew up with her and creates a Content
piece and says you know I'm sure I I
didn't know this was Ashley chelle's
friend but hey you are and she comments
on the box and everything and she's like
of course Ashley doesn't know me so
thank you to the pr team right and and
so we caught on to that we're like you
know what won't it be so nice that Ash
we surprise her that actually Ashley
does know her right so so what we did
was the team was on top of it a you know
so we quickly saw that this was taking
traction so we're like okay let's let's
now work this algorithm right like let
is let it go viral we quickly got in
touch with Ashley Ashley didn't waste a
minute she quickly created a stitch with
that Creator and suddenly she had just
posted two videos and now came a third
video her crying hysterically that
Ashley had created a video with her and
was noticing the whole thing and Ashley
posted on her channels too and she of
course is a huge followership in the
course of 48 hours I think we had
generated four million views you know
and over half a million likes and and
we're still counting because then we
decided to boost the content pay the
influencer some usage rights boost the
content and really give it further legs
because guess what relevant content
performs an algorithm so when you boost
an ad like that is far more successful
than a paid campaign salesy brand ad you
know so so great great example of that
and I hope that we have many more
moments of it and continue to see that
Revenue impact you know that's obviously
the reactive right that's obviously you
you've seated it but that's the reactive
tell us your philosophy on the proactive
when you look at your Brands and Eng
your brand leads how's the team thinking
about using creators using the platforms
like what are some like for the next
year ahead what are some um headlines
that that that they're kind of working
under the offices that they're working
under that they want to see creators
with their brands right are you talking
more from a proactive like outre
proactive Yeah Ashley story is amazing
and it's funny I went back in and looked
at a bunch of um the Tik toks and
Ashley's commenting left and right right
and we know that so much of the content
happens in the comment section but tell
us more like proactively how are you
thinking about employing creators yeah
no I think I think so there's multiple
layers to it right so um first layer is
truly the founder let several of Our
Brands not all of our Brands like finer
is a brand that we have it's not founder
like but several of Our Brands would
have start with founder at the peak of
it because they are almost the
mouthpiece of of the content um that's
been created right now if I were to
really pull apart my two very large
brands CH and Heritage for instance
right Christen Very itg Girl brand the
the aesthetic of it it's it's beautiful
blush pink it stands out it's still the
only female hairdresser Le brand that's
out there in Mass categories which still
surprises me but hey I'll take the
differentiator there right um but but
there when we think about how we're
building that pyramid it's very much who
are those it girl influencer consumers
who are also lifestyle they transcend
into makeup they transcend into hair
because hair is such a big part of how
you look and it's hairdresser Equity so
not only that that we need to build out
the hairdresser Equity not only that
because Christin has started off her
career as a celebrity hair stylist so do
we need to have a presence in the red
carpet do we need to partner with Glam
Squad and be in those really affluent
consumers households and giving those
treatments and services right and then
on top of that how do you build the army
of micros and Nanos and then on top of
that hey can we do something on Tik Tok
shop and make it be something relevant
right um it's a very different go to
market Market compared to Heritage the
founder is Mindy mcnight she is a very
well-loved mom on YouTube she started
her career creating hairstyles for her
girls right good old American amazing
values right so so the way we build her
pyramid and amplify her voice is very
different the influencers that we target
are very different you know we look at
more Whit space American moments like
Bama Rush is a really relevant moment
for her right and it's such a specific
moment but it's very resonant to her
target audience and her community right
so so as you can already see proactively
just same team right very similar kpis
but performing very differently and who
they Outreach yeah so again as you said
before the science is similar you said
something interesting when we've caught
up before about how it is science but
then you have to remember the human
story of creating on the platforms what
do you mean by that you know it's all of
it is just Art and Science right like I
could tell you scientifically what leads
to a viral moment right but can I
recreate that Viral moment because I
know the science hard now right it boils
down to Content it boils down to
relevance and even as we find our
founder partners and it's not something
that I manage we have a very strong team
who does that you know it's not just
anybody with a huge following can be a
founder of a brand there's a specific
Art and Science that goes into of course
the science is your followership your
engagement and we're watching you the
content you're creating Etc but the art
of it is are you going to have the the
skill set of a Founder are you going to
understand what it is to be an
entrepreneur are you going to be able to
work hard in the way that it would need
for you to build this brand from scratch
and or c on it right like it's it's that
piece I can't nail for you that's just
art and that's where the more you do it
the more you experiment the better it
gets you know in the last conversation I
think a good point was we often talk
about what we're doing in our own teams
what we're doing that we're seeing
success with where do you see and please
no specifics at all but where do you see
brands take a wrong turn with with
creators especially I think when it's
inauthentic I I I I honestly mean that
you know you're just partnering with the
person just because you think they have
the followership and and and that's it
and you know in the end you can pay your
way through anything the world of
marketing right like anything can be
bought with money what can be bought
with money is relevance and authenticity
and the type of content you put out
there and I think that's what a lot of
the missteps have been um for Brands
when you don't truly know your target
audience and you make some wrong calls
and who you pick you've said before in
other interviews you've had oh Andre
you're peeping having too much
fun I know such a wealth she's this
could be a whole a whole uh introduction
to marketing introduction creators I
think that's right I think we're gonna
have our own episode with o what do you
think would love that would love that
anything for you guys oh my goodness
well I hate to Hate to disrupt it but
love to you both thanks for joining
thanks thanks
Andre all right next up let's bring up
Avery
akinini Avery is our new Global
CMO I am so excited to bring you up
Avery and you're not new to Vayner
that's for
sure no but uh got a big new uh shoes to
fill with taking on your role Andreas
you catapult into something amazing
outstanding that I know everybody in
this audience will be tuning in to see
what happens next oh well thank you so
much yeah Avery comes she stood up our
Asia Pacific uh region which is the
fastest growing and then went on to be
president of Vayner 3 so um yeah so
excited to see where you take us from
here but first we have a very important
conversation today with Alex Morrison
who is the CMO of paop and I'm gonna let
you guys um share a little bit more
about what paop is this is uh this is
the perfect show for you very excited to
hear what you have to say all right
thank you so much Andre and Alex thank
you for joining us um and for sharing
your insights on how what you all are
building at paop and how you're helping
both creators and Brands and being that
sort of pair matching in the middle um
so can you tell us in the marketing for
the now audience a little bit about
yourself and a little bit about perp
yeah sure uh first of all thanks thanks
for having me on and you know I think
it's been tuning in so far there's a lot
of amazing themes we're hearing already
I think in the conversation so you're
going to hear a few more of those things
drilled home uh in our conversation I
have a feeling so Perot uh we're the
leading uh Creator collaboration
platform we help Brands unlock Creator
collaboration at scale what you've been
hearing from a lot of the marketers that
have been on so far um is it's really
important to get that match just perfect
it's really a brand alignment between a
brand and a Creator and what we help
Brands unlock is the brand right
collaborations at scale so doing it
again and again because the right
partnership uh with a Creator might last
uh post it might last a month it might
last a year but continually discovering
and activating the right creators uh and
learning from what works in the market
is something that we really help Brands
accomplish one thing that's really
important to us too is that we're a
Creator first company so our mission
first and foremost is to help creators
earn a living doing what they love um
and that means that we built the largest
community of creators coming up on
250,000 creators who are users and so
for a brand Market marketer or digital
marketer what that means is you can tap
into our community in a very TurnKey way
and so we're reducing a lot of the
friction of finding and activating the
right creators um and that's led to a
lot of really exciting uh growth for us
we're only a three-year-old company uh
and in that time we've we've grown
tremendously and you know lots more to
come it's it's feels like a big year ahe
here in 2024 for sure yeah it's the year
of the Creator economy and it's been
amazing to hear sort of Ashley's
perspective and that you know creators
get paid campaign and um also what
they're doing the beauty industry with O
and you're kind of in the middle of all
of these right you're across multiple
different verticals and both on the
Creator side and on the brand side and
in three years you all have catapulted I
recently joined your Advisory Board and
I've been really enjoying learning a
little bit more because you all have
been on this rocket ship so what's the
secret like how is paop different than
the many other sort of Creator matching
tools that exist out there I mean I
think it starts with the fact that we
are Creator first so I think a lot of
marketers really want that
disintermediated access to the right
creators for their brand so the fact
that we have creators uh swimming around
at perpa uh is a real Advantage I think
for us um and uh really for us it's all
about helping Brands win with creators
and creators win with Brands if either
of those things isn't true it's really
not a sustainable uh Arrangement right
no one's trying to take advantage of
anyone here um and so the secret I guess
if there is one is our Dynamic matching
algorithm um that really is pairing the
right Brands and creators at scale as I
mentioned so really looking Beyond kind
of surface level metrics like follower
count engagement rate things that anyone
can see with the naked eye right and
really get a lot deeper into the
characteristics that make a Creator a
great fit for a brand and a brand a
great fit for that Creator um and what
that enables us to do and I think one of
the things that um they're probably two
or three things that Brands say after
they've partnered with us that are very
different about the parp experience the
first is really getting that brand
alignment uh right again and again and
again because our matching algorithm is
so finely tuned um the second is
reducing friction so like we all know
like creators they're real living
breathing people they they don't just
stay put it's not a pixel you know
sometimes I feel like there's a lot of
AI creators these days Alex that's you
know that's increasingly true we could
talk about that for a whole session but
I mean the the the fact of the matter is
um you know ultimately there's a lot of
friction in the creative space and I
think it's it's it's actually kept it
from growing in the past where it's like
well you know there are a lot of things
I could do with my time and with my
marketing budget uh this just feels
really like sometimes you can feel the
gears grinding uh when you're trying to
get the right creators activate them
understand what performance is going to
look like in any meaningful way um and
so one of the big things that you know a
lot of our brand Partners will say after
let's say they finished a program with
us is man that like that really actually
felt very smooth and part of the reason
is because we're using our technology
and our platform to put the two sides
together uh and to make that interaction
really really um you know easy for
everybody and then the the third piece
is knowing what's going to happen I
think a lot of times with creators in
terms of business outcomes right and so
I think a lot of times with creators
you're kind of taking a BET right you
kind of feel like well I've done all my
desk research I've I love this person's
feed they feel like a really great
alignment but what's going to happen you
know beyond sort of upper funnel metrics
like
Impressions uh you know engagements
things like that I think a lot of
marketers now are being gold on actual
business performance and so being able
to design programs that don't just speak
kind of like the pr language but speak
business um and be able to design
programs that really move the business
um predictably like call it beforehand
right call your shot it's really kind of
important um and so we help marketers
really think through how to design these
successful programs um that that move
the needle for them whatever that looks
like it could be purely brand or it
could be you know something more lower
fun
accountable to business results we must
be at a Gary vaynerchuck event because
this is the thing that he talks about
all day every day um but Alex uh you
know it sounds like your matching
algorithm has some like really
interesting characteristics I've got to
ask how is AI in the mix are you all you
know developing things that take
advantage of sort of AI
capabilities AI um in the Creator
economy is is probably one of the best
topics we could be talking about two
buzzwords together
UNIF so yeah no I mean definitely so we
are U but creators are too so I mean you
mentioned just before we dive into the
parp side of this um there are AI
creators more and more of them there was
you know pretty U widely circulated
article about a a Spanish modeling
agency that created their own AI uh
Creator uh to to basically show up for
gigs because they were having trouble
getting real people to show up for gigs
uh so like this is a new thing uh that
we're add on one thing there because I
think this is really interesting some
Brands who are listening to this might
remember like Lil Michaela some Brands
who are international might you know
remember um EMA this virtual influencer
in Japan who's been big for many years I
remember like five years ago we did a
shoot with EMA in Japan um and it they
kind of went away for a little while
like Lil Michaela was like a big thing
for a bit there and now it has come back
in such a big way at least from our
perspective oh big time Big Time I mean
and if you even look at it you know in
terms of real human creators I mean
adoption of AI as part of the creative
process proc is you know off the charts
I mean some some recent surveys have
said that as many as three qus of
creators are using uh AI to enhance
their creation process whether it's
coming up with content ideas uh in the
in the process itself so Ai and creators
it's it's happening right and here at
ppop um the way we look at it is AI is
uniquely great at helping us with kind
of these large data sets right and so
when we're thinking about pairing the
right creators and brands at scale uh
not only can we ingest a huge amount of
data because we have both first-party
data and third party data on creators
and the brands that we work with and so
we're able to make much better
recommendations as a result of machine
learning in AI but then the more at bats
right the more campaigns we run the
smarter our system gets and the more for
each individual brand we're able to say
look these are the creators who worked
for you last time now let's start
thinking about adding those folks to a
roster we'll start making those
recommendations dynamically um and a lot
of that um is is made smarter and faster
by AI so um so absolutely it's it's
really if you think about some of the
core blockers that have kept the Creator
economy from really reaching full um
full growth potential and I think a lot
of these are going away by the way um
you know AI is poised to really remove a
lot of those a lot of those pain points
amazing um Alex last question for you
and we'll try to cut this to one minute
because I know we've had a long episode
um can you tell us like a campaign that
you all are really proud of that you've
recently done or a piece of work that
you think really speaks to how perp
helps unlock um you know creators and
culture totally I mean there there are
so many that we could probably talk
about but one that I I really like is
something that we were fortunate to be
involved with last year for Chipotle um
and maybe anyone listening heard about
this Keith ailla Keith Lee and Alexis
Frost it kind of happened organically on
Tik Tok and this is kind of the
beautiful thing about creators is sort
of by by listening to culture seeing
what's really happening and really is
relevant to people people um Chipotle
jumped on what was basically a food hack
on Tik Tok um prominent food creators
were creating these sort of like
quesadillas with fajita vegetables in
them uh and giving it a perfect 10 score
all this kind of stuff and rather than
sit idly by Chipotle actually created
this as a menu item that was available
on a limited basis and then we used
creators to promote this uh limited
edition menu item which was only
available through the app uh and what
ended up happening was we created the
sort of surround sound of Creator voices
to promote this item so it was kind of
this full circle thing where it was born
from creators promoted by creators uh
and ultimately what ended up happening
was it was the best digital sales
weekend for Chipotle of all time had the
most app downloads they've ever seen so
uh for anyone who thinks that creators
cannot drive hard business results uh
think again right they definitely can
it's all about wiring it up the right
way and tying it into really things that
are happening in culture and driving
that relevance so I think that was a
nice example of of how you can really
you know hone in on something that's
happening and put some gasoline on it
with creators and drive some real impact
it's a theme that we're hearing across a
lot of these Alex thank you so much for
joining us for sharing your insights and
for anyone anyone listening who's
looking for a tool to help pa pop check
it out you got it thanks guys appreciate
than you both thanks for
joining all right let's bring up Chris
Anthony our chief Revenue officer of
gallery Media Group Chris how are youa
how are you you're trying to stay warm
warm and snugly like I am I mean I need
that fur around your neck it's so cool
so true well we're gonna create some
fire here we've got Andre Branch joining
us uh SVP and GM of Mac one of my
favorite from Estee Lauder um and Andre
is he he's hosted an he's held a number
of different leadership roles at Great
companies including L'Oreal Nature's
Bounty and diio and more I'm very
excited to reunite you guys uh and have
an exciting conversation today take it
away amazing Andre good to see you great
to see you again Chris how's everything
it's good you know besides the frigid
cold temperatures here but excited about
this topic and it feels like mac is
reflective of some of the good
conversations we've had to date so
excited to dig in with you absolutely
looking forward to it yeah awesome um
but yeah I think you know you guys have
such a story Legacy I think that to me
culture and sort of what you guys had
built the brand on from the Inception is
so reflective around some so many great
topics from inclusivity and authenticity
um but let's dig in some of the topics
and sort of how we really understand
what culture and is happening from a
Creator standpoint is is really done on
the platforms these days right um
starting off with Tik Tok um is such a
core platform I think to everyone's
strategies how are you thinking about
that platform I know we're going to talk
a little bit later about some specific
collaborations as well but talk a little
about how Tik Tok fits into what you're
thinking about the brand from a culture
and Creator lens
yeah of course well I would say first of
all the you know just digital expansion
really allows us to bring to life what
makes Mac Mac to consumers in new and
innovative ways and on social we're
constantly building Community uh we
launched a dedicated Tik Tock and uh
Instagram Pages for the US and that's
separate from our Global channels
because we wanted to engage specifically
with the consumers here uh and we've
invested a lot in influence of
Partnerships building relationships with
creators who are influencing culture uh
our art artists many of whom are
influencer in their own right have all
been trained and and always encouraged
to have a social presence so you can
learn from from them as well uh online
not just in the store um looking at Tik
Tok specifically it's where Jin Z and
Millennials are which really makes it
table saakes from active play uh we log
hours on the platform daily uh and
always in in close contact with our team
at Tik Tok just to make sure that we are
spotting the trends we're jumping in on
the right ones at the right time um as
we as well as just upskilling our teams
just to make sure they've got best
practices in place um I'll tell you
about an example on Tik Tok that we use
to connect to our younger fans during
National lipstick day so anyone watching
lip content on Tik Tok will always see
Mac in a lip combo whether it's a
lipstick or pencil or gloss our lip
products are really used by a lot of
creators in their content so we tapped
into this trend and partnered with three
creators that created their own uh Mac
lip combos that we sold in all of our
director channel uh directed consumer
Channel channels for for National
lipstick day um our partners were jod
Woods we had Cindy Kimberly we had uh
Alyssa Ashley all of whom dreamed up
their own favorite lip combos using Mac
and uh the response was just
overwhelming it was amazing we saw
creators artists consumers uh all
running really to buy that Creator lip
combo set and they created a lot of
content for us replicating it on Tik Tok
and uh during this time we saw our EMV
really jump it increased um we were
number five and number three in EMV
according to tribe in July and August
respectively um when the campaign was in
the market so really really great
campaign for us and then Beyond seeing
the buzz the program actually drove a
lot of new buyers to Mac it was really a
success all around so you know we
reached our our crators um uh also
responding in in real time um late last
year uh prea came on our radar I don't
know if you know him but um he's got
this this these these devotees called
Pooky
um and he started out making videos from
his car in four weeks he grew from like
30,000 to 4 million followers really
amazing uh and fans really embraced his
his demeanor and loved his authenticity
and he built a personal connection with
them um so we reached out to him he
thought it' be a great partner uh put
Mac on his radar um his growing fan base
and he had so many ideas we just we
landed on this very simple creative
concept to tell the world that Pooky is
actually a Mac girl um so he filmed some
things in store
uh he attempts to to go on the shopping
spree for Pooky at Mac picking up things
asking her about you know what she
thinks and highlighting uh all the
things that jiny and Tik Tock uh jiny
consumers love on for us and then Tik
Tock faves and they had 1.6 million
views on on on the video which is
incredible so you know Tik Tok is is an
amazing platform for us it's possible to
do a lot there you just really need to
have your ear to the ground and just
know when to jump in that's what I would
tell you well that's such good examples
of collaborations and spotting and sort
of building the deeper relationships um
with some of those collaborators you
mentioned I think even the point of
talking about the artists and sort of
like them being an influencer in their
own right um and has been such core to
the brand so so true and the whole
Community aspect is such an interesting
thing to think about when you think
about a lot of this um overall like how
we move through this world of fast
moving culture and social and Tik Tok
and everything's changing constantly for
these younger Generations that are
driving so much of culture what does
agility mean to you and sort of how do
you move quickly and that could be
whether that's externally to make this
stuff happen or whether it's internally
with your team how do you think about
just moving quickly in order to bring
all this to life which is definitely not
a a easy task to accomplish yeah yeah
not easy at all I mean um you know Mac
is a true culture brand and to really
have that title you have to move quickly
uh we really pride ourselves for not
only capturing the moment uh or the
momentum on Rising Trends but also just
uh being Trend Setters ourselves so you
know one day we're wearing latte makeup
and
then the next day it's their Sugar Plum
Fairy make uh really uh get after these
things because to be successful today we
recognize that you really need to be
able to move with speed uh and that's
where Ma Tren comes into place for us so
our brand is really the ultimate color
Authority with really an array of
products Tove Trends and trends no
longer move through this biannual
fashion calendar right it used to be
Fashion Week driven now Trends are
really moving a mile a minute thanks to
social media and our agile approach
really is to to meet consumers at at
their Pace that starts with um our
Global Trend team you know they Source
Trends through a combination of math and
Magic leaning on social and and search
tools as well as inputs from our
extensive relationships in in fashion
and in film music editorial
we've got artists all over the world so
we're constantly getting data and input
uh that we understand we understand when
something's really bubbling up and uh
with their help for example we predicted
um the soft goth Trend that really took
off last year soft goth glamour was on
the spring summer 23 runways and at the
2022 Met Gala and shortly after that uh
the Netflix show Wednesday launched and
that was a breakout hit um and we
supported the makeup lead on the show
who really spoke about creating this
soft golf look for the Wednesday
character using um Mac lip pencil and
night moth fans jumped in recreating the
looks which really spiked Sales Online
searches and inore request of the
product and so we quickly mobilize our
artist Community to demonstrate how to
achieve that Trend um across social in
store so we have a system set up that's
very very reactive uh and being Mac and
being the number one presed Beauty brand
we're able to really leverage our our
Synergy and our our scale to take
advantage of those moments I love that
the math and the magic such a great way
to look at it and I think ways that you
guys have reacted and been able to
amplify with some of those examples is
is super smart talk a little bit about
you know when I think of mac and the
beginning you guys always represented
diversity and inclusivity I think before
the world woke up and realized that that
should just be the norm in what was
happening um with marketers and how do
you balance really like authenticity and
and your constant commitment to
diversity with also you know chasing Rel
within the ever world of culture today
how do you balance sort of those two
truisms knowing that that's been such a
core to the Inception of Mac yeah yeah
for sure
um I would say like every aspect of our
brand our our journey uh really starts
with with a consumer Mac has always had
a very loyal consumer base and the
Brand's Legacy of inclusivity was key to
this uh and in fact many diverse
consumers can trace their first Beauty
experiences back to Mac so as our
consumers evolve and new generations are
really introduced uh such as jinz or
Millennial Millennials our brand really
um has to stay constantly tapped in to
what those consumers want and what they
need and we really love partnering with
culturally relevant voices who help us
drive those conversations and Trends
larger than Beauty uh and with the rise
of Tik Tok you know anyone can really be
a Creator uh because anyone can find
viral success but what we look for is
something far more important when
creating our our brand building
relationships and what's important to
Mac as you mentioned or or three things
one is alignment with the brand values
right so we really honor diversity
individuality and self-expression above
all else uh and we believe everyone
should should be free to use makeup to
tap into their authentic identities
we're committed to creating a welcoming
community on social and ensuring diverse
representation um and so we do that we
do that with the folks that we work with
we have uh our Matt crew uh for example
which is an ensemble cast of always on
social creators who fully embody those
values while also reflecting what the
consumers uh are trying to achieve or
want in a particular La Tour initiative
uh so that works for us I think the
other thing that's important uh is
create creativity and quality of content
you know the content quality always
needs to be there it's a reflection of
the brand we always think if I were a
consumer watching this what would I
think uh would it resonate with me and
our influencer team watches hours of
content a day to really Scout great
creators uh and then you need to trust
the creators to be the experts right in
they're creative um giving up total
creative control may seem a bit uneasy
for some but we know that our creators
know the brand and that comes with just
a lot of research uh but by investing in
creators who really understand the Mac
brand the creative process has been for
us very seamless and the end results
have been very very strong I think the
last thing I would say is you know uh
people really need to be a lover and a
user of Mac you know authenticity is an
influencer buzzword because audiences
have really become much more Discerning
with the marketing being so saturated at
and they value content that they feel is
genuine that's transparent that's uh
really relevant to them uh and consumers
like Jin Z really want content that
feels more organic which means that adds
uh a more integrated into the content
that speaks to them as opposed to just a
hard marketing cell um so we really
sharpen our focus on aligning with
creators who use Mac or or some kind of
way have a natural connection to to the
brand um and this really also extends to
the creators who who will continue to
support the brand organically over time
even after the pay you know part ship
ends so um this for us is a relationship
that feels much more
holistic I love that and I think that's
such a great takeaway in the sense that
it's if you pick and Source the right
people for the brand the trust is easy
to have because those people are
innately already trusting you guys so so
great congrats on all the amazing work
um and excited to all the future work
that Mac and your team puts out
awesome in the chat there thank you so
much Andre thank you thanks Andre Che
stay warm all right we're down to our
last conversation last but not least we
can bring Avery back up and we're gonna
bring Jeff from Dell who is live from
Seattle where apparently the power has
completely gone out but that's not
stopping Jeff something to be said about
him uh I hope you're doing okay Jeff is
everything okay out there I am yeah
thanks for having me today good to see
you both oh my goodness yeah well we're
we're thrilled to have you Jeff is the
senior director of digital marketing at
Dell and what I love is he's not only
immersed in B2B marketing and all things
Tech and media but he's also he is a
part of Pop Culture so he's a Creator
and a DJ and an artist himself uh so I
think there's going to be a lot of Juicy
stuff coming out of this conversation I
will leave it to the two of
you amazing thanks Andre and Jeff really
appreciate you joining come H high water
or no power here you are so we're so
pumped to have you join marketing for
the now today yeah thanks for for having
me Avery awesome so Jee can you tell us
a little bit about yourself as Andre
said you're Creator you're a marketer um
tell us a little bit about you and what
you do at Dell yeah I've been at Dell
now about the last year and a half uh
senior director of digital marketing you
know leading a team in terms of you know
how to grow the brand how to grow sort
of different solution areas product
areas um also company you know if you
think about it Dell's 40 years old this
year was founded in 1984 uh we still
have a CEO founder Michael Dell still
you know involved in the day-to-day so
that's sort of a rarity out there so I
think that's been quite interesting um
you know prior to Dell spent almost a
decade at Microsoft uh and then spent a
long time in in sort of the New York
agency World ogal v 360i a lot of
Boutique shops um and uh yeah that's
actually how I sort of discovered Gary
ve way back in the day is working sort
of in the early 2000s and sort of the
boutique World cool and in your
day-to-day life now um in a world where
we're sort of constantly adapting to new
trends and platforms what is Dell doing
to stay relevant after 40 years in my
mind I will never forget the line like
dude I'm getting a Dell that came out
like when I was going to college I think
but like what are you all doing these
days um you know the to keep at the
pulse of
culture yeah I think the interesting
thing is you know what the company now
does it's much more Diversified it's
it's I think sometimes it's hard to
explain when you sort of sit down with
others and you're like Hey we're we're
more than just um in in the PC world I
mean you know we're we're heavily
involved I think in in sort of data
protection storage servers
infrastructure things that actually
enable businesses to operate whether
you're a midsize business or an
Enterprise business so I think those are
areas that are interesting that we like
to talk about but you know of course you
know we still have sort of our entire uh
you know PC business that that that's
highly relevant and and I think the
interesting thing there is you know
becoming a little bit more simplified in
terms of how to define what our you know
what what what enables people to do
their sort of most important work you
know whether they're a Creator
themselves or they're someone that works
for a large
corporation and at Dell you all have
worked with so many different creators
over the years can you talk a little bit
about your approach there and your
approach to sort of prioritizing
existing customers and users um versus
just folks with a big
following yeah I think the interesting
thing there is you know Finding and
working with people who are you know are
fans of the brand so not just going out
and doing you know a deal or an
endorsement which I think a lot of other
companies do where it's like hey who's
the most popular who can we tap into to
extend our brand I think the approach
has been hey who uses our brand because
they get us and how do we you know tap
into that I think the other thing that's
interesting and it's it's an an area to
watch is uh you know last year we took
you know a lot of the creators that work
with us to our proprietary events so we
had them there in person where audiences
could talk to them ask them questions
Etc I think that that IRL movement that
we're going to see this year um you know
you're going to see more of that so not
just sort of creators online but how do
you take them to these in-person events
um and then I think the other thing
that's been interesting with working
with you know creators as well is you
know being humble in the sense of hey
how do we feature you in our content
Beyond just you making content for us so
you're sort of seeing this conjoint
effect Avery where um you know Brands
want a credibility Factor so they're not
afraid to say hey let's actually have
this person in our content as as well as
them making content for us then that way
when a user whether they're following us
on you know one plat form or they're
sort of following a Creator on the
platform they're sort of seeing these
similar messages um of empowerment from
the brand which I think goes a long way
yeah it's funny you bring that up um you
know it's Super Bowl season so I'm
thinking back to like four or five years
ago and we actually put a lot of
influencers in a Sabra hummus commercial
including Charlie demilio before she was
Charlie demilio today and that was a
very like you know new new crazy
Approach at the time and now to your
point this is actually something that so
many brands are doing is taking these
you know born on um social media stars
and putting them um across other pieces
of content
um yeah go ahead I was gonna say it's
funny you bring that up because I think
that was highly Innovative and I think
you're gonna see in this Super Bowl
Round I'm gonna make a you know sort of
a give us a hot take you know I I do
think you'll see a lot of ads during the
Super Bowl with a lot of creators
because I think it's mainstreamed now I
think what you did years ago
was was highly Innovative and that was
sort of scary for a lot of companies
like wait we don't want to feature these
people who are only you know popular
online but now most people have someone
that they follow online and that you
know they feel like they know those
people and so I think we're going to see
a lot of that in you know Super Bowl ads
and that'll open up the Gateway as well
if that works you'll see those ads rerun
at the Olympics or Copa America there's
a lot of big events this year so I think
this is New Territory where instead of
the celebrity athletic endorsements
we're now seeing Creator endorsements
sort of become mainstreamed yeah it's
really like blurring the lines of like
what is a celebrity is a celebrity just
born uh in Hollywood or can they be born
on social media and have the same amount
of you know Starpower um because I think
that like redefinition of celebrities is
happening right in front of our eyes um
right now because a lot of the biggest
celebrities are the biggest creators and
vice versa um but I want to double down
on one really interesting point you made
around bringing your career creators to
different places so almost like using
events as a place to generate content
I'd love to hear more about how you all
are thinking about that at
Dell yeah I think the big one you know
we have a proprietary event it's our
largest event of the Year takes place in
May in Vegas which is Dell technology
World um you know that's a big one that
we are always going to bring creators to
not only to speak to audiences but to
create content because that's you know a
great place to do it I think a lot of
third party events that will be you know
big sponsor of we'll also look to to do
that as well Mobile World Congress you
know number of things that that are sort
of on the the the industry calendar and
I think those are things that in the
past you would go as a company and say
all right we're going to speak on stage
maybe we'll have a keynote but now you
know Avery I think a lot of companies
have been smart the past couple years of
saying wait a minute this is an entire
opportunity for us to create some
content the content may come out you
know while you're there or maybe it
comes out a week later because it's it's
still relevant and on top of mine for a
lot of people I mean I saw so much this
year from creators during CES in the
past I remember five years ago being the
the one sort of Creator at Vegas that
was sort of creating content and
everyone looked at me like what are you
doing now I you know I didn't go this
year but I had heard from many creators
basically took over the entire event and
were is making content on the floor and
and and sort of releasing that in real
time 100% and that also really helps
tell the story of what's happening at
CES for the people who are there some
people are there in Vegas but like the
vast majority are not and they might be
interested in sort of those highlights
and amplifying a message especially if a
brand has invested significantly in
having a big presence so I'd love to
know a little bit some of like your
favorite Creator Partnerships um you
know something that stands out to you
maybe in the last few months or the last
year that you saw and you were like wow
that's amazing
yeah I think you know big one is is that
we've worked a lot with is Corporate
Natalie um you know good sense of humor
not taking yourself too seriously I
think is is really important you know
being able to laugh at yourself um you
know uh we worked with a Creator called
wa gatheru you know a little bit smaller
but you know really into sort of the you
know running a smaller business um you
know basically a a female entrepreneur
you know thing I think you know these
are people who when you meet them you're
like hey I get so many ideas from like
watching your content that sort of is a
that's sort of what our brand is is
about is is sort of motivation and
empowerment you know allowing you know
Humanity to really unlock themselves
using technology so I think that's a big
thing too in terms of how Brands go and
find you know their their sort of
exclusive or non-exclusive deals with
creators is like you know are they an
extension of your brand do they really
sort of you know walk the line of your
brand if they do those are those are
great creators to do deals with I love
corporate natal so much she reminds me
of myself when I lived in San Francisco
many years ago just like her whole vibe
and lifestyle I just like personally
resonate with that so much and I love
the work she's done for you all and Sofi
and some other partners um I know we're
running tight on time here so Jeff in
our last minute I'd love to hear where
is Dell going for 2024 give us a sneak
peek of some of the things that you're
excited
about yeah I think one of the big things
that I'm excited about just is the the
the fact that you
know creators aren't going to supplement
creative directors I think you know
those who don't have large egos realize
creators play like a role now I think
you know I I want to I want to sort of
see more from creators in terms of hey
how do you influence what our larger
creative is out there that we that we do
and I think you know we're getting maybe
setting ourselves up in for 2025 a year
from now where you know you have someone
who's a chief Creator officer at the
company um that you know they're not a
full-time employee but they're really
sort of tied in with everything that uh
the brand does and and they're really
sort of helping Implement a lot of of of
you know creative Direction and again
you know Avery this isn't new if we look
at you know some of the bigger
celebrities who were named creative
directors in the past that was a common
thing with Brands now what I think we'll
see is instead of you know um you know a
larger celebrity who's the creative
director you'll you'll really have
someone who's a more of a popular
Creator who becomes sort of like a chief
Creator officer that's sort of My Hope
on where how we unlock the you know the
best creativity um I think the other
area though too is you know how are we
going to use some of our own employees
who are quite big subject matter experts
they become interesting and unique in a
in in this world um I think a lot of
companies sort of shy away from that
except some of the more Progressive ones
who realize wait a minute these are
great evangelists good ambassadors they
make really interesting content why
don't we unlock their you know potential
to do more of this so I think you're
going to see a little bit more of that
which you know takes sort of takes over
from what companies had done in the past
which is hey we have a evangelists on
staff but they would go out and talk at
events we have much more scale now you
don't need those people necessarily to
do that they could make things and
release them daily weekly Etc and have
just as much impact on on a business now
amazing I love how you're kind of
echoing some of what Andre shared as
well that your employees can be your
best Advocates and use them for social
media content creation as well whether
you're in cosmetics or you're in
computers so jeoff thank you so much for
joining us and sharing your insights
thank you that was fantastic you guys I
love that so much that conclusion all
right well the first episode is wrapped
up we'll call it a wrap for January
Avery you're G to be killing it with the
next one that's coming up on February
7th at 12 noon Eastern uh can't than our
community enough we've had 47 episodes
hard to believe 415 speakers so far and
we'd love to hear from you what you'd
like to hear next so Avery happy to be
handing off that baton
thank you Andrea and everybody
give hope to join on the show in
different capacities in the future
absolutely everybody give it up for
Andrea thank you for tuning in for
marketing for the now and we will see
yall on February
7th see you